the Microsoft biology foundation or mbf
for short is a language neutral
bioinformatics toolkit built as an
extension to the microsoft.net framework
mbf includes parses for common
bioinformatics file formats algorithms
for manipulating DNA RNA and protein
sequences but a set of connectors to
biological web services such as NCBI
blast mbf applications can be
implemented in any of over 70 dotnet
compatible languages including C sharp F
sharp visual basic and iron Python
programming guides are included when you
install mb f mb f is part of the
microsoft biology initiative and effort
in microsoft research to bring new
technology and tools to the areas of
bioinformatics and biology Microsoft
Research recognizes the need for
reusable bioinformatics libraries of
high quality code and the goal for mb f
is to provide a development framework
for the bioinformatics community that
ensures high architectural and coding
standards necessary for the ease of
application extensibility and longevity
mbf version 1 was released in june 2010
and is currently in use by researchers
around the world now let's take a look
at some of the improvements and features
available in this beta release of
version 2 first off the object model has
been redesigned to be more memory
efficient allowing us to scale to
genomes that are much bigger than in
version one we've added a new assembly
algorithm to do comparative assembly
which consists of five steps a line
reads with new comer which you will see
running here repeat resolution layout
refinement consensus generation and
scaffolding we've also improved the
parallel de novo assembly making it more
scalable in addition to these
refinements we've included a host of new
command line utilities including mum
util which you see running here as well
as a range of other command line
utilities making it easy to access many
of the other features inside the NBF
library also included in this release of
the sequence assembler and the biology
extension add-in for microsoft office
excel the sequence assembler is a
proof-of-concept application that
demonstrates the use of the microsoft
biology foundation dotnet framework and
windows presentation foundation for
bioinformatics research the MSR sequence
assembler uses rich user
face elements to enable the
visualization and manipulation of
genomic data the biology extension
provides a simple and flexible way to
work with genomic sequences metadata and
interval data in an Excel spreadsheet
the add-in implements several features
of the Microsoft biology foundation the
set of passes for common genome file
formats a set of sequencing algorithms
for assembly of consensus DNA strands
and a set of connectors to several blast
web services for genome identification
mbf is a community curated open-source
project which is available for academic
and commercial use under the apache to
license binary source code demo
applications and documentation of freely
downloadable from mbf codeplex com so
download develop and deliver thank you